ever since parents began to cosseting
their children at the Saturday matinee
while they went shopping movie stars
have been influential babysitters and on
the way home all the little boys wanted
to be Douglas Fairbanks all the little
girls wanted to be married Pickford or
Tom Mix and Lillian Gish after the
movies began to talk every little boy
wanted to be Gary Cooper and all the
girls Clara bow or William Powell in
Marin alloy a few years later boys
wanted to be Clark Gable and the girls
Jean Harlow then the boys wanted to be
John Wayne and the girls Betty Grable
then the boys wanted to be John Wayne
and the girls Marilyn Monroe then the
boys wanted to be John Wayne and the
girls Grace Kelly finally things changed
a little the boys still want to be John
Wayne but girls want to be John Wayne
two sisters may I present the only one
is gonna be John Wayne here tonight is
the Duke himself Marion Morrison
thank you I'm here to given an honorary
award to a motion picture director the
actors hate directors they hate them
because when actors have given their
everything directors want more
boy I'll they hate that when they see
themselves up there and scratch the old
black and white I go back that far our
glorious Technicolor in 20 feet high
better than they ever thought they could
be doing things that they never thought
they could do they don't hate the
director anymore they love it
that's all I feel about this man Howard
Hawks if you think there's anything
between us
it certainly is for pictures Red River
Rio Bravo Atari and Eldorado I don't
think their only reason that the Academy
Board of Governors voted him an honorary
award they're just part of a list that
reads like this Don Patrol
Scarface bringing up baby sergeant York
the crowd roars Viva via his girl Friday
to Heaven have not I was a male war
bride and the big sleep he's made a lot
of actors jump so it's time we made him
do the same tonight he's not the
director I am hawks ready to roll get
your skinny watching McCall it out here
I'm going to tell you hard for movie
fans everywhere and I'm one of them
Thanks thank you dude I'm gonna tell you
a little story Jack Ford and I were
friends he was a better friend with Duke
thank God and when he became sick and
came to the desert to die I used to go
over and see him we'd talk laughs and
then we got to telling each other the
things that we'd stolen from each other
and we all tried to remember all of the
things I tried to that I took him
forward and he did for me one day he was
laughing
and he said there's something I took
from you that beats the whole things
that I may have picture there wasn't so
good and you made sergeant York and he
said I got the award and he stopped in
the middle of laughing and he changed
just as Duke knows other people he
changed quickly and he said you're gonna
get Owen Ward and I said I don't think
so he said god damn it you're gonna get
in the war so I would like to thank the
Academy for making that prediction of
his come true thanks very much